I want to give you an update of where we
are with covert 19 which parts of
England Wales the UK are being affected
by it and how Britain compares with
other countries right now and the good
news is there is a little bit of good
news here and that's not from one can
say that about this disease but you can
see the average number of people who
died at this time of year this line just
shows the total all cause mortality in
previous years so this relatively flat
line shows you the weeks we're in at the
moment this kind of season around Easter
and I'll bring on the 2020 line and you
can probably spot it there is the
coronavirus effect excess deaths rising
very sharply indeed above that line when
we talk about excess deaths it's just
really anything above that dotted line
so anything above the average but the
good news is that is that after that
peak it has started to come down hasn't
it so that black line is getting a
little bit closer to that like blue
dotted line and that would indicate
getting back towards non-patent
normality that really matters by the way
what we've got here is all cause
mortality it's not just covert 19 I'll
give you a little illustration of why
that matters see if we look at care home
death same kind of story again so again
this line showing you the normal number
of people who died in care homes in
England and Wales and I'll just add on
the numbers that you tend to hear about
a lot so that's there you can see
official covert 19 deaths taking it just
a bit above the total the average level
over the course of the past five years
but the reality is actually there have
been a lot more deaths in care homes
that can be accounted for by covert 19
diagnosis something else is going on
here and we don't really have a very
good explanation for what but what we do
know is an extraordinary number of
people are dying
particularly in care homes and this has
been a kind of relatively late
development in this story because
initially most of the deaths happened in
hospitals and you get a sense for this
by looking at this chart this shows you
again the line the bottom line here zero
I've just averaged out 0 is is average
number of deaths by different setting
and you can see deaths at home so in
domestic settings have risen up
relatively shallow and they're starting
to come down a bit above the average but
have a look at this hospitals you can
see a very sharp increase in mortality
in hospitals and again this is all cause
more time
for those reasons you saw a moment ago
we're not quite sure if that why there
are other excess debts but it's clearly
something is going on up very sharply
but look at where we are at the moment
week 19 that we can see we're below the
line that means fewer people dying in
hospitals right now than normally do so
that is that is quite a striking
statistic there but here's what happens
if you add on care homes just have a
look at this line at the care homes line
and this really is the the big story in
England and Wales and indeed in the UK
it peaked after hospitals but it got
even higher more deaths in care homes
than in hospitals more than in home and
it happened later and look at that black
line it is above the average still right
now that's kind of equivalent to what I
showed you a moment ago but you really
see it there this domino effect from
hospitals passing through to care homes
where the real epicenter of the crisis
has been in recent weeks and you get a
sense of the scale of it when you're
just kind of add up the total amount
that we've got there above the line
that's total cumulative excess deaths
I'll just put them in two bars here so
you get a sense of what we're talking
about here so at home about kind of
twelve twelve thousand or so excess
deaths at home above the average at
hospital around 16,000 above the average
over this period cumulative deaths from
all causes look most of this is covert
nineteen it should be said but some of
it isn't as well but just look at care
homes by far and away the most excess
deaths have been in care home spoil and
double what you would normally expect
around this time of year and to
underline that a little bit more because
you know this really is the most
striking story right now when it comes
to covert 90 number of people dying in
care homes at the moment what I'm going
to do is just show you this this line
here just shows you the average again
you've got to depressing it as as
compare it to the average from recent
years around this time of you might
expect around 22,000 people to die in
care homes actually right now in England
and Wales alone it's up to about 15,000
49,000 at the moment over this period
that's some people also dying in
hospitals who are care home residents as
well just a small number of them as well
add on Scotland as well in Northern
Ireland and you have a total number of
deaths of care home residents of 53,000
742 since March that's total not just
excess
total deaths but to put that into
perspective that is about 1 in 10 of the
total care home population one in 10
more than 10% of the total care home
population have died in the course of
this outbreak it is a striking striking
statistic and underlines really what's
for happening beneath the surface in the
UK I said I compared the UK and indeed
England and Wales to other countries
around the world because you'll have a
sense of how our different trajectories
compare so what we've got here is again
the same kind of thing we were showing
you earlier so this area here is
considered normal range and what we're
going to do is show you different
countries around Europe and how their
kind of curves so above normal down
towards normal compare now you can see
England that's a familiar line you might
have seen a moment ago excess that's
above average and I'm going to show you
a few other countries as well these are
compiled by someone called euro Momo and
have a look at this Wales is back down
towards the normal range the key thing
here is the pattern the shape of these
lines Scotland getting back down it's
close to the normal range as well
Northern Ireland getting close in fact
is below average at the moment so below
excess deaths at the moment Italy also
rose higher rose earlier but has come
dat back down to normal levels as well
similar story to in Spain went even
higher than Italy in terms of excess
debts but now back down to the normal as
well look at France below below zero at
the moment so you have fewer deaths than
normal this time of year
in France although it was a lot higher
beforehand because they had a serious
outbreak in France as well Germany never
got beyond that normal range Sweden too
a lot of focus on Sweden and whether
their lockdown has been different it
certainly has been different the way
it's been implemented it's it's it
hasn't necessarily prevented them from
having a big increase in deaths but
they're back down to the normal level as
well
but the real outlier we saw earlier it's
England with excess deaths still well
above the normal levels aside from the
u.s. it's difficult to find another
country in the developed world that's
facing this problem so you can see and
that's largely a problem from care homes
that really puts it into perspective